let me pull this article this this
article absolutely blew my mind it's
from neiman lab which is like a
journalist you know college
organization how a conservative comic
became the most popular late night host
on tv
gutfeld
fox news the most popular late night
host the funny thing about this
is that they're very clearly leftists
who are trapped in a cult where they
lack the ability to see outside of their
bubble
and they view greg gutfeld's success as
an aberration on their system
completely oblivious to the fact that i
believe it was jimmy kimmel who did
blackface
when is how that has not never come up
they talk about gutfeld doing edgy jokes
and conservative comedy that the left
would find offensive but the right
doesn't care
uh yeah they all used to do that it's
the craziest thing right
gut fell you know here's how i imagine
greg gutfeld and fox news's you know
pitch for the show went down before they
decided to launch it
godfeld walks into the office and they
go like hey remember when late night
comedy was funny yes i do okay here
there's the show uh we'll air at eight
go for it that's it
they they they were like we're gonna do
a normal comedy like comedy used to be
before it was woke
do normal things americans like
but late night comedy on the left is
just like vaccine
did you see the the syringe thing with
colbert
who watches that and they're like i
relate to that i i was embarrassed yeah
well
real quick it's like remember those
cartoons you'd watch when you were a kid
about like you must brush your teeth yes
i know you're going to leave me like in
greece in greece when they show it like
in the 1960s on the on the drive-in
theater it's like that
reminded me of you know what i'm talking
about
that's what it is but like adults are
watching this yo mike i think it was
mike stern which we tweeted that boomers
are like the first generation that
hadn't moved past adolescence and i'll
tell you this this next generation
that's watching cold bear as he does
these things they're like permanent
children like toddlers i have disliked
colbert's art for
15 years i made a youtube video in 2006
which i'm sure you can find on my
youtube channel where i criticized him
for basically
lying to people with his you know he'd
be like oh i'm playing a character but
he come on and be like war is good and
he'd do this like weird conservative
aberration and it was like he would lie
and lie and lie and now he got a new job
as a tonight show host and he's still
trash he's doing the exact same thing
but nobody's left us now well if you
look at his previous show on comedy
central it was actually edgy it was
actually somewhat comedic it was
actually kind of ironic satirical he was
plying up this kind of conservative
personality and questioning a lot of the
wars questioning a lot of the security
states questioning a lot of the
intelligence agencies he even brought up
bilderberg he literally like i had
conversations with him about bilderberg
and other very serious legitimate issues
uh i have those videos still on my
youtube channel luckily but something
changed when he went on the big networks
and he's literally doing big pharma
commercials with dancing needles
promoting
a medical procedure that he says should
be mandatory for everyone to take jimmy
kimball's no better i mean all of them
regurgitate the same talking points
jimmy campbell was literally trying to
make a joke about how people were in the
hospital because of ivor
of of of a readily available pill that
we can't mention we can talk about it um
jimmy kimball was literally spreading
fake news as a joke saying how gunshot
victims couldn't have help at a hospital
because everyone there was overdosed on
this uh pill that's readily available
that i don't even know if we could say
on this platform uh in fear of possibly
taking what are the rules for this
channel down i don't know i don't want
to people know exactly what i'm saying
i've been talking about it since last
year by the way it's ivormectin yeah and
youtube's rule is that you can't
recommend it that you have to inform
people that is not fda approved for the
treat as a treatment for covid and that
you should talk to your doctor about
what's right for you before you know
taking any medications which i i i agree
with you yeah i agree with those
statements right so it's not like
i i think the issue is that that bothers
me that i haven't complained about is
that you can literally there are people
who go on youtube and say don't talk to
your doctor just go to a parking lot at
a 7-eleven i'm not i'm not even right
that's dangerous yes some of the biggest
youtubers are like go down to a local
parking lot where they're doing this and
and i'm like i'm tweeting like hey you
should talk to a doctor man like yeah um
and then i love it when the leftists go
that's stupid the doctor would just
recommend the vaccine and i'm like then
why are you mad at me like
okay yeah there's something weird about
them being like don't go to your doctor
like they're mad that i'm telling people
to actually consult medical advice yeah
maybe because they want people to just
walk down to the parking lot without
asking any questions about what their
medical treatment is just listen to the
out of touch politicians that are
working for the corporate heads they
know what's best for you not your
medical doctor and professional because
you know possibly you might have
something like antibodies you might have
a medical condition
you might have an underlining condition
your doctor knows what's right for you
and there's also a purge happening with
a lot of doctors being censored which
also needs to be addressed because when
we're reaching a phase where medical
data studies
professionals experts in the field are
being punished for providing raw data i
mean that's that's such a dangerous time
right now and then and then this is i
don't want to deviate off of the you
know we're talking about i was going to
talk about the the health care workers
that were just fired in new york we'll
get into that too i just you know for
those things i don't want to deviate too
hard we're talking about greg godfeld
and colbert and then it starts shifting
a little bit too much i do want to show
you the image so you can understand
we're talking about this is colbert with
dancing syringes called the vax scene
and the weirdest thing is the people who
watch the show are probably all
vaccinated they don't need to see this
and the people who aren't are not going
to be convinced by this weird behavior
that they find strange that's literally
what i thought of when i watched that
that clip i said nobody is going to
nobody like myself or whoever does it
you know because i had covet i talked
about it on on a video um no one's being
convinced by nobody nobody on the on the
right or let me let me show you this
real quick i want to read this for you
from the from the neiman lab article
they say hiding in plain sight despite
its growing prominence right-wing comedy
remains largely invisible in both
mainstream and scholarly discussions of
media and humor in part this happened
because social media algorithms don't
send users jokes likely to challenge or
offend their political sensibilities let
me just point something out
i follow mainstream media they talk
about mainstream late-night hosts all
the time i follow conservative media
they sometimes will talk about gutfeld
what happens i get a balanced news diet
showing me what the conservatives are
talking about the moderates and the
liberals and liberals in mainstream
media only see what's happening in the
liberal sphere they have no idea what's
happening
how does it manifest you can really tell
if someone's in the cult an american
idiot controlled by the media when it's
it's as simple as you know like phil
defranco coming out and saying the
covington kids were wrong and bad
when when the covington thing happened i
get sent all these videos like tim look
at this are you angry and i saw the
video i'm like i have no idea what's
happening it was just a picture of a it
was a video of a kid with like a drum in
his face and he's like smirking or
whatever and i'm like
what's happening but people just
immediately like it's bad because we
said so even people were supposed to be
doing news and then i started looking at
the live streams and immediately it's
like i made a video saying the media's
lying about the covington kids they
didn't do anything wrong and then all of
a sudden one by one all these new news
outside issuing corrections and updates
but you can easily just look at the the
personalities even on youtube or
whatever who are in the cult and not
paying attention to what's happening
outside of their bubble and and the
crazy thing is they're getting angrier
and angrier like i'll bring up phil
defranco again because i used to think
he was awesome i was like this is right
he's an independent entrepreneur then
all of a sudden he's tweeting how he
hates people and he puts his harm on
them and i'm like whatever is in that
cult bubble is becoming increasingly
angry and violent echo chamber we also
have to realize these people see a
different news feed than we do these
people are curated information that's
regurgitated that they want to hear
again and again um and and by and large
late night television is dominated by
the same neoliberal corporatist uh big
totalitarian talking points except for a
few deviations one of the most
significant ones that
uh is very prominent to me is the guy
who looks like my dad bill maher he does
an excellent job and and i don't always
agree with him i don't always agree with
him but i think he does provide some
kind of context that does deviate from
the agenda the narrative and he does
start an interesting conversation even
though i don't agree with his opinion on
the conversation at least he starts one
we gotta lose
he's doing a little better he's doing a
little better but bill maher was also
wrong on the covington kids yeah a week
of course a week after the corrections
bill maher came out and was like what's
up with that and it's like dude you're a
week like they've already issued
corrections on this
i talked about it you know seven days
before he came out
and did a show but i will give him the
respect for at least standing up and
saying this is going too far what's
happening to this country and now you
know what really was the bridge making
breaking the the the bridge breaking or
the strawberry camelback camel's back is
bill maher issuing a quote where he's
like i'm getting attacked for
criticizing the left too much
ding ding ding there it is bill maher
smart guy all of a sudden you're
starting to realize the republicans
aren't doing anything they're sitting on
their hands the waste of our time they
act like they're supporting us they
don't do anything i don't care for them
oh i like what i hear like oh that's a
good agenda item school choice sounds
great and then what do they do nothing
the democrats meanwhile are like we're
going to burn it down so what are your
options bill maher all of a sudden is
criticizing the left because the right
the republican establishment does
nothing oh bill maher could rag on
marjorie taylor green but i'm sure bill
mars in there like she's a freshman
congresswoman why do i care
well if you want to pie along with the
establishment that's the target he's
like an observant uh comedian that talks
about the news but i don't think he's
ever claimed to be a journalist or
anything like that of course not yeah
well he has a late night show that he
does every friday night and he does have
people like ben shapiro on i have a lot
of things to criticize ben shapiro on
but at least there's another voice from
a different spectrum compared to of
course stephen colbert jimmy kimball
that have the same nonsense again over
again spreading fake news spreading this
information spreading i mean that story
about the hospital being overrun with
people
from poison control uh that was an hour
in oklahoma in oklahoma i mean that
story has ramifications that story could
actually hurt people that story uh is
having real life consequences i mean
imagine someone in the third world
country who's taken that specific
medicine for the specific use of saying
hey i don't want my you know i don't
want to be poisoned because of this hold
on it's ridiculous i want to elaborate
on that so there was a story that went
around from large mainstream leftist
publications that ivermectin was
sterilizing men now imagine so
ivermectin is used to treat river
blindness it's a parasite in the eyes it
is not fda approved for for treating
covid but in africa it is considered an
essential medication by the u.n
imagine you you have a country right
when they got ebola
in north africa
you had people
fleeing quarantine thinking that these
people were coming in and infecting them
or killing them or harming them
so they would literally like take
ebola-infected bodies and run and then
it would get worse it would spread now
imagine you have these people in these
villages it is mostly rural african
tribes that have river blindness and
along comes the u.n saying we want to
give you this medication to cure you of
your blindness
and then they're like they they hear
these stories but on the internet in
america they say it takes away our
ability to have children it sterilizes
us either that's the most psychotic
conspiracy theory i've ever heard or
these people are more crimes against
humanity
look i think you're posting that
information is a crime against humanity
my point is the un is not sterilizing
small poor african tribes they're trying
to cure them of river blindness i'm not
a big fan of the un and and their
ineffective you know whatever it is
they're doing for the most part but when
they're like we're going to cure
blindness i'm like sounds about right
that's what ivermectin does and then the
media comes out with and it also
sterilizes men because it was like a
study of 30 people and like eight had
reproductive issues and now you're going
to have
you have the risk of misinformation
freaking people out and bringing back
river blind that's the crime against
humanity yeah posting the misinformation
well if you go on the nih website and
you look at the medical studies
surrounding ivermectin especially even
the preliminary ones i don't want to get
this channel in trouble but just do your
own research do your own homework and
look at the medical studies and make up
your own decisions and have those
serious conversations with your medical
professionals it's as simple as
you know look there's a lot of people
who are like oh the the censorship yes i
will say it right now
there are certain medications you two
will ban you for recommending and others
they expect you to recommend no no i
don't play any of that game i don't give
financial advice medical advice or legal
advice and if you and when people
message me all the time saying oh but my
doctor's not smart my doctors are bad
i'm like then you've got a bad doctor
man i have to say it over and over again
people are probably saying tim you've
told us this 50 times i know but i got a
super chat last week saying the exact
same thing where they're like but i have
a dumb doctor i'm like why why not go to
a doctor that isn't dumb have you
considered that i mean you're paying for
it one way or another either through
your taxes or your insurance you're
paying for that medical care i don't
know why people think that medical care
is you know
something that they're giving to you
that's that's voluntary it's not you're
paying for it in one way or another and
and when we look at our history
especially in the medical field they
have failed us time and time again and
it's important to note especially with
the opioid epidemic we had very serious
problems very serious ramifications from
medical professionals uh being bought
out and lying to people giving them
medications that they knew was bad for
them
being given false information having
criminal activities that were literally
done by many medical professionals
literally making people heroin addicts
all over this country well tuskegee even
biome brought it up the this he
experiments right that's it so it's like
look man a healthy individual is is
skeptical but not overly distrustful
they they try to get by they try to do
some research but ultimately we'll try
to trust the experts and it's a very
very difficult and narrow path to figure
out but there's personal responsibility
in there thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you